[Musique]
une cérémonie minutieusement orchestrée
dans une bulle sanitaire étanche et une
ville placée sous haute surveillance le
président chinois participe au 25 ans de
la rétrocession de Hong Kong
la vraie démocratie a commencé avec la
rétrocession
persécuté par le régime chinois la
Winkie a fui Hong Kong il a construit
son refuge sa librairie dédiée à la
liberté à Taipei
il affirme qu'il n'aurait jamais pensé
il y a 25 ans que Hong Kong puisse être
détruite si rapidement par le régime
communiste chinois
[Musique]
l'ancienne colonie britannique devait
jouir d'une certaine autonomie selon le
principe d'un pays d'un système mais la
loi sur la sécurité nationale imposée il
y a trois ans à anéanti les libertés
promises
la Chine réécrit même l'histoire appelle
cette activiste on connaît exilé à
Taïwan selon les nouveaux manuels
scolaires Hong Kong jamais été une
colonie britannique
il croit que Taïwan mais aussi le reste
du monde dont le au Canada devrait
retenir les leçons de Hong Kong
[Musique]
à protéger pour sauvegarder la
démocratie croient-il
la mwinkie lui sans que c'est sa
responsabilité de défendre Taïwan il
organise des séminaires et il rencontre
jeune et moins jeunes dans sa librairie
pas besoin de prendre les armes pour se
défendre dit-il on peut lire pour mieux
comprendre la présidente de Taïwan elle
soutient que l'anniversaire de la
rétrocession de Hong Kong ne fait que
renforcer sa détermination à défendre la
souveraineté et les libertés de Taïwan
ici Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada